[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos estamos muy
contentos de que esté de nuevo con
nosotros en france 24 y radio francia
internacional
nos estamos acercando al final de esta
segunda aventura a bordo de la estación
espacial internacional con tu mapa es
que el astronauta francés que regresará
a la tierra en poco más de un mes la
estación espacial internacional está
ocupada permanentemente por una
tripulación desde hace 21 años y hay que
reabastecer la así que ésta acoge
regularmente a naves espaciales enviadas
desde la tierra para proporcionarle
apoyo logístico y también los
suministros a esta estación hoy en día
hay tres operacionales el progress que
es ruso aunque voló por primera vez en
1978 y es la más antigua también hay dos
estadounidenses la cyrus es lanzada por
un cohete el antares y luego el space ex
que también desarrolló su propia nave de
suministros la dragón que transporta
seis toneladas y es la única capaz de
regresar a la tierra en especial con los
experimentos que se realizan a bordo de
esta estación todas las demás naves de
carga se desintegran durante su ingreso
a la atmósfera a partir del año que
viene la estación será reabastecida por
la agencia japonesa lay axa que enviará
la htv x con una capacidad de carga de
casi seis toneladas estas naves
espaciales de suministros que se acoplan
a la estación espacial internacional
son un encuentro espacial así se llama
esta delicada maniobra este es un
procedimiento que la mayoría de las
veces está totalmente automatizado pero
a veces los astronautas tienen que
encargarse ellos mismos de la captura y
para ello cuentan con una herramienta
mítica la primera versión equipo el
transbordador espacial la segunda está
instalada en ahí ss y es la canadá arma
el brazo robótico canadiense como su
nombre lo indica este es un equipo
especial para esta estación pero no es
precisamente muy fácil de manejar pero
dejemos que sea toma pesqué quien nos lo
explique toma adelante
hola a todos hoy vamos a hablar de las
cabinas de mando de la estación espacial
la estación espacial
la estación espacial hay varios lugares
desde donde podemos controlar ciertos
elementos de la nación
el primero es la estación de control del
brazo robótico hay dos brazos a bordo
dos de las pasiones sociales uno está en
la cúpula que permite ver el exterior
este lo usamos por ejemplo en las
aproximaciones de los vehículos de
cargas que vienen las que vienen a
situarse debajo del sistema de social
estas capturamos con este brazo robótico
de 17 metros que se controla desde la
estación espacial también tenemos uno en
el corazón de la estación en el
laboratorio médica es esto que ven acá
es lo que más se parece a una cabina
tenemos un joystick que parece un
joystick de avión aquí tenemos un
segundo elemento de control en un panel
para los comandos que no son los más
urgentes por así decir computadoras que
nos permiten acceder al sistema tres
motores que hoy están apagados porque no
hay operación pero que nos permiten
visualizar las vistas de las cámaras que
están afuera de la estación que nos
mostrarán haciendo porque aquí
obviamente trabajamos a ciegas no
tenemos una visión directa tenemos
visión a través de las cámaras este
joystick sirve para controlar las
transacciones del brazo robótico es
decir de izquierda a derecha arriba
abajo adelante atrás y este yo esté aquí
es para comprar las rotaciones las
rotaciones diseñadas las rotaciones de
cabeceo las rotaciones de balanceo así
que controlamos seis grados de libertad
es un poco complicado de imaginar en el
espacio pero así es como controlamos el
brazo robótico y también tenemos
controles con gatillos e interruptores
como la cabina de un avión que sirve
para agarrar más o menos de la mano lo
que llamamos el detector de nuestro
brazo robot otros comandos que a veces
son un poco más importantes pueden ser
por ejemplo separar una pieza del brazo
robótico si alguna vez el mecanismo se
atascara tenemos pernos exclusivas que
nos permitirán liberar una nave para que
no se prende contra la estación por
ejemplo si alguna vez el mecanismo se
rascará tenemos tirarnos es
liberar una nave
por ejemplo son comandos que esperamos
utilizar
y para terminar en un día típico de
funcionamiento de los días las personas
aquí los seguimientos comunicándose con
la tierra hablamos de estas ese día con
sus manos en la escala de un avión de
pasajeros y el otro estaría controlando
y luego se cambian los papeles este es
uno de los lugares de la estación donde
se puede controlar algo de formativa y
manual es el brazo
y no olviden que cada mes tomates que
nos entrega detalles de cómo es su día a
día en la estación espacial
internacional y los avances de su misión
y ustedes lo podrán conocer sólo aquí en
france 24 gracias y los invitamos a
seguir con nuestra programación hasta
pronto
[Música]